off you go hit this story louder oh well
basically tonight was very exciting for
me because from the time I was about 13
years old I used to have a kind of
fantasy or dream about mr. Stallone
being my father just like one of those
things okay
okay off you go
you didn't know yeah he was my husband
Cumberbatch and I were actually at the
same boarding school we both went to
Harrow and there are lots of rumors
circulating about what he got up to
there so cool
[Applause]
I've got your back you didn't only have
it alright so I'm sorry this story is
going to put someone on the spot on that
stage I'm one of three girls about ten
years ago I was on holiday in Dublin
checking into in Dublin International
Airport a my 11 year old sister starts
watching someone check in and she runs
up to this person and says oh my god are
you man Hathaway and then turns around
whips off her sunglasses and says hi you
can call me Annie and then you know
proceeds to interact and talk to all of
us asking how our holiday is posing
pictures with us it was so nice it was
so lovely and that would have been a
really great story had it ended there
however left my mother then just started
crying hysterically about how nice and
Hathaway was who naturally none of these
people had any context and naturally
thought she was batshit crazy for being
so lovely and nice and for making
okay so about three years ago I went to
London to go to the premiere of The Iron
Lady so I meet Meryl oh my god
so I took my mum and my best friend
we kept missing her as she was like
making her way through the crowds and my
mum got fed up with the cold and went
into the National Theatre by the time we
found her she was drunk
and when I say Tron I mean steamin your
mother my mother
[Applause]
[Music]
so we went so like take my mom back to
the hotel we went past the premier again
um she was talking to the security
guards and she told them that she was
there Undercover Boss and Secret
Millionaire
Meryl came up to the after-party and was
like she got into a car and we were like
I was spying we see you know I'm so
happy and the window was down a bit in
the front of the car and we were all
like oh I'm so cold I'm so cold
and Meryl got out of the car and came
and meet me and my friends and my mum
was like thanks Meryl babes you could
walk so when I was a student I had a
part-time job I worked as a film extra
and and I did this little film called
Gulliver's Travels
with Jack Black and so we're filming in
this in this field outside Pinewood
Studios and it was very very very hot
and I had the flu so I wasn't feeling
very well at all and
[Applause]
he's gonna get sick on somebody
do you remember somebody vomiting on you
it's a vague recollection of yeah some
flu bug going around yeah I knew it was
gonna end in a horrible bodily function
I've got three older brothers and back
in the day we found out Titanic was
coming out we were all very excited as
as a four of us at Kate Winslet you know
you saw us in the car to the cinema and
that's really you know we watched for an
hour and a half of you know Titanic and
as it came up for the scene my mom sort
of covered my eyes like this and all my
brothers got to see and I was so angry I
walked out and sort of got grounded
[Applause]
no I live in London but I'm originally
from Suffolk oh yeah it's a Suffolk
massif is he mentioned in the song
probably ya know what school did you go
to um so I went to Brandis then oh so
yeah well I with the promise primary
school okay did we know each other yeah
[Applause]
yeah James yes me that's the one and now
you're talking to him honestly he's
right oh my god Oh can we not flip them
and just get them out of here do you
have a sari or do you boy yeah I did but
it's leaves let it be about okay then
we'll flip you and then yes yeah when we
were younger ed used to come around to
my house and yeah like you saying we
used to be quite good mates and I
remember one time one time he's come
round for tea and I forgotten to tell
mum who's a vegetarian at that point
anyway and so mum cooked
I think the sausage and mash for tea and
Edie said you know after the meal these
are the best sausages I've ever tasted
you know where did you get them from a
mum had to lie because she had no clue
sorry
first time I ever had me and also the
first time I ever watch The Simpsons
episode was around yeah we could be
reunited backstage
I feel like Cilla black on surprise
surprise
[Applause]
Renda me have a seat have a seat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]